you're welcome to this video playing
Darla dash Lee does sleep yeah many
opportunities Joan flag okay let's play
a green pawn opening here quit porn game
not nothing fancy Queen d6s a good line
here let's see if he knows that very
strange move I known the idea screen
before check or queen h6 quite quite
weird with them okay c5 is perfectly all
right of course and queen bee 6mm queen
bee three yeah maybe
yeah I can play c4 quite often this
exchange on b6 assume is good for the
side with the doubled pawns okay he
decides to play it in another way hmm ok
let's see maybe I can get a little bit
of something because of my good
development but we've been slightly
better developed yeah i was thinking
happy five but this is nonsense of
course he's got Bishop before check yeah
this is so quite disappointing yeah be
sure before now I guess maybe can imply
Knight a5 now attacking be three yeah
yeah wow this was this was a completely
completely miss played opening wow talk
about ugly chess okay maybe I give this
check can't maybe maybe this this way
and try to check get some play going
based on on 95 check here's some time on
f7 so maybe there's something maybe
there is something here if I am
um b3 is hanging if i move the King King
it to for example night be three night x
if I there's a check on c1 hmm what
about f3 Vigo f3 yes still night xb3 a
don't now came come on I need to play it
Sam it's not not great anyway whatever
i'm playing maybe still acting to what
would have been better making sure that
I actually can connect rooks and move
the night at some point the knight on c3
the only slide hope is that he cannot
castle this is this is in fact helpful
if I am I don't know if this was a good
idea checking is six now and and b3 so
maybe he needs to exchange and then I
have 95 maybe maybe maybe I'm getting
I'm getting a little bit of compensation
here this is actually interesting
he's six I can play six it doesn't
change the Eddie
ok let's try to open up the center
against the King you form if you place a
5 I take g5 the night hangs
Jack m93 covering d5 what a shame how
bad can you play what the heck he really
left me into this game again I had a
good position i'm pretty sure but now
this is just just plain stupid now and i
can just take you 1
or that one taking d one was better I
think okay it doesn't matter probably
ah what the heck he really left me back
into this game and then I just
squandered it away again check check
check
it still do they can I do something he
always plays in exactly like like you
like you get some hope again it's
probably lost anyway still King situ and
rookie to
yeah whatever I don't I don't have any
great move from anyway check
hmm yeah funny now he threatening g5
made after taking on g2 don't I cannot
really prevent that I hope on Luke takes
96 yep time warning check
yes I'm still I'm still trying check
yeah and why on age 6 what the heck
still still complete draw check yeah I'm
far too slow in white for face on time
yeah well it's a it's a fair result I
don't know maybe a 0-0 is the fairies
off we both played this like complete
morons I completely completely butchered
the opening yeah and then yeah for some
reason I got back into the game and then
I i squandered it again so rocky I don't
think it's too bad then I need some
precise moves the diet that I fail to
find yeah dad this weakness only three
is just it's just too bad it's just too
bad okay yeah blackest completely
winning in many ways of course and yeah
I don't know why he sent the King to
this journey but it was winning all
along and here also i bought everything
wins this also does win books is six ok
ok this also still wins for black
obviously ok but somehow it did
continued and continued that he had
Saddam would be to for instance but this
just loses because I whoops you six also
I didn't see that and okay this is this
is a draw but I had only six seconds
left
so this is probably more like a
demonstration how to not play chess
alright thanks for watching anyway